et on reste dans la culture avec ce
festival de rock qui fête sa deuxième
édition cette année qui a lieu à
l'estaminet c'est à Magny-les-Hameaux ce
week-end pour nous en parler je reçois
le bureau de l'association food rock au
complet à peu près Stéphane diphossé
bonsoir vous en êtes le président à vos
côtés Guillaume Le tocard vice-président
et face à vous Pascal les cuivy vous en
êtes le trésorier bonsoir à vous alors
pour commencer comment caractériser ce
festival un festival de rock mais encore
l'identité artistique du festival c'est
on va dire c'est du c'est du rock du du
blues du blues fondateur jusqu'au métal
ravageur tout ce qui se joue avec une
guitare électrique un temps soit peu
saturé ça c'est l'identité artistique du
festival alors quelle est la
programmation de cette année
nous avons
cinq groupes dont deux têtes d'affiches
nationales qui sont et le chargeur et
acné donc qui est très connu du public
jeune et moins jeune et ensuite on a ces
le travail qu'on a essayé de faire c'est
d'amener des groupes un peu moins connus
pour associer finalement des groupes
locaux donc on va trouver stuff session
qui sont de la région parisienne un
groupe teinté funk et il est trop jeune
Busters qui sont de 3 donc on couvre un
peu plus loin que que la région et
locomo RT qui vient finalement un groupe
intermédiaire qui vient entre ces têtes
d'affiches et ses groupes plus locaux
plus
jeune on va dire comment vous arrivez à
faire venir des groupes je m'adresse au
trésorier parce que ils sont rémunérés
ces groupes sur tous les têtes
d'affiches absolument ils sont rémunérés
alors donc il faut distinguer quand même
les professionnels donc là il s'agit
d'un cachet et on est en relation avec
leur manager on passe un contrat et
ensuite avec les amateurs ou ceux qui
souhaitent devenir professionnel donc là
on va leur payer comme c'est les non
professionnels alors leur payer leur
défraiements donc ils n'auront pas de
frais liés à ce festival quand on est
comme ça en région parisienne on peut se
dire peut-être que c'est moins attractif
qu'une scène parisienne est-ce que c'est
difficile de faire venir cette aide
d'affiche
on n'a pas eu de difficultés
particulières pour les pour les faire
venir le le projet
c'est une histoire de réseau le projet
les séduit et puis ils se sont ils se
sont inscrits dans ce projet
c'est parce qu'il n'avait pas de
festival de cette emploi ou cet acabit
que vous l'avez créé c'est une idée au
départ au départ c'est moi j'habite dans
La Valette Chevreuse il y a des forêts
des des champs et quand je me promenais
en voiture je me disais mais il y aurait
de quoi faire un joli festival et tout
et j'ai commencé à en parler tout
d'abord avec Pascal et qui a tout de
suite adhéré au projet et puis là-dessus
il y a plein de personnes qui se sont
adhérées qui qui ont été séduits par
l'idée et on s'est mis à construire
constitue la sauce et à construire ce
festival alors pour l'instant on est
allé se terminer mais c'est vrai qu'on
envisage avant de sortir dehors
en extérieur en esprit en état d'esprit
oui
les attentes du public comment on fait
une programmation
c'est nos goûts on est tous musiciens
rock voilà c'est aussi une passion ce
qu'on dit pas on y passe du temps donc
forcément on a tous des rêves ah tiens
j'aurais bien que ce groupe ils viennent
donc ça joue effectivement oui ça
rejoint le nom finalement qui est food
rock qui qui a un trait d'humour
finalement par rapport à notre passion
commune qui nous anime et il y a aussi
le les groupes qui composent cette
affiche ont tous une actualité ils ont
tous sorti un album en 2012 donc ils
sont dans un cycle de promotion à
tourner etc et on fait partie des dates
par exemple pour acmé on fait partie des
premières dates par rapport à la sortie
de leur album être charger Vienne assez
peu souvent ce qui viennent de Caen donc
ils viennent assez peu souvent en région
parisienne donc voilà tout ça c'est un
ensemble on va dire un écosystème qui
fait que on propose une prestation qui
est attirante pour le public attirante
pour les groupes avec toute une passion
qui nous anime qui permet de de
fonctionner
ça reste au trésorier l'année dernière
200 entrées cette année combien est-ce
que vous vous espérez en faire et puis à
quel prix donc
déjà l'objectif qu'on s'est donné c'est
de faire au moins 300 entrées et on
espère bien plus
on a une jauge publique qui nous permet
d'aller jusqu'à 600 entrées donc venez
alors cette année le prix est de 12
euros donc effectivement il y a une
augmentation par rapport à l'an dernier
qui était de 8 euros qui s'explique par
le fait que l'an dernier on avait eu de
grandes faveurs par rapport au tête
d'affiche cette année c'est un peu plus
sérieux donc il faut pouvoir financer et
le financement doit se faire en partie
par aussi par les festivals en payant
leur place et sinon le reste
des subventions des dons privés
dans l'entreprise ou de personnes qui
veulent nous aider et qui croient notre
projet et c'est pas trop difficile
bah écoutez c'est bien simple c'est il
faut rencontrer les gens
discuter donc c'est beaucoup de temps à
passer et au fur et à mesure on crée un
réseau et donc d'autres personnes nous
aident et ainsi de suite on arrive à
contacter les bonnes personnes qui sont
prêts à nous aider et une dernière
question vous êtes tous les trois
musiciens on le disait est-ce que vous
n'avez pas aussi envie de peut-être
faire une scène ouverte pendant le
festival pour des jeunes talents
en fait
tout à l'heure on parlait de des groupes
locaux typiquement stuff session et l'an
dernier c'était le cas de de groupe de
avait remporté des tremplins locaux donc
en fait on travaille avec avec une école
de musique qui organise un tremplin et
donc on est il y a nombre de personnes
de l'association qui sont qui sont
acteurs
notamment le directeur de l'école qui
fait partie de l'association et on on va
à ce temps plein et puis on fait aussi
notre marché
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
activités
en juin ce qu'on appelle le foudre
sculple qui était en partenariat avec
notre partenaire vol se laisse là qui
est un fabricant de bière oui donc on
anime etc voilà on va pas le citer
des facilité donc voilà donc on fait on
fait une animation effectivement on
essaye de créer une communauté via les
réseaux sociaux etc donc on a ça grossi
et effectivement on a on a un certain
nombre d'activités dans l'année qui nous
permet de pérenniser l'événement alors
on rappelle cet événement c'est ce
samedi 13 octobre à partir de 17h à
l'estaminet à Manille les hameaux prix
d'entrée 12 euros il y a également les
t-shirts qui sont en vente à 12 euros
que vous voyez devant sur nos invités
merci à vous trois d'être venu en
plateau merci beaucoup